all right when declaring bankruptcy it's
easy to think certain actions won't
affect the process eric palacios from
eric palacios and associates and
sponsors of this segment tells us three
things to avoid if you're going to
declare bankruptcy
hi i'm eric palacios and welcome to this
week's legal minute the question for
this week is what are three things you
should not do if you're going to declare
bankruptcy number one do not run up your
credit card debt or worse get cash
advances from them the bankruptcy
trustee will see this and flag your
bankruptcy as fraudulent and may dismiss
it number two do not hide assets you
might have a motorcycle a boat a utv or
other items that can be considered
luxury items if you try to hide them the
trustee will find them and your
bankruptcy will be dismissed or worse
you could face fraud charges number
three do not continue to make payments
on your debt
continuing to make payments on your
credit card debt hospital bills payday
loans is just throwing your money out
the window once you talk to your
attorney once you know you're going to
declare bankruptcy stop making all your
payments this has been the legal minute
don't forget to
download app eric palacio's legal app
we'll see you next week
if you'd like more information you can
give eric palacios and associates call
dot
702-444-7777